et pire tado infectiologues et chef du
service des maladies infectieuses du chu
de rennes estime qu'il est important de
commencer à vacciner les enfants
ya vraiment deux bonnes raisons de le
faire la première c'est que quand même
les enfants l'air beaucoup plus sensible
aux qu'ovide avec les nouveaux variants
le delta et puis le microbe qui arrive
derrière on a l'impression que ça
circule beaucoup plus chez les enfants
que ce qu'on connaissait avec les
variants antérieur et puis quand même
c'est vrai que c'est quand même une
partie de la chaîne de transmission pour
les adultes pour les personnes âgées
pour les fermetures des écoles tout ça
fait que si on peut diminuer la
circulation du virus chez les enfants ça
sera pas une mauvaise